من غلاف غزه تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان اذا يبدو ان هناك دوي
لصفه الانذار في عده في عده مستوطنات في
غلاف غزه ما الذي رصدته من الجانب
الاسرائيلي نعم بالفعل قبل قليل غنو دوت
صافرات الانذار في منطقه غلاف غزه الجنوبي
تحديدا في بلده
صوفا و حوليت وحتى الان لم يتم التبليغ
فيما اذا كان هناك سقوط للقضائي
الصاروخيه التي اطلقت لكن في الواقع طيلت
الوقت او يعني عده مرات خلال النهار تدوي
صافرات الانذار في مناطق مختلفه في غلاف
غزه خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه سواء كان
في المناطق الجنوبيه او شرق قطاع غزه
وايضا في البلدات المتاخمه للمناطق
الشماليه يوم امس كانت قد دوت ايضا في
ديروت في مدينه ديروت وعدت وعدد من
البلدات ال في الغلاف لكن حاليا تسمع
اصوات قصف متواصله ايضا لهذه المناطق التي
تظهر من خلفنا شرق قطاع غزه تحديدا حي
الشجاعيه التي لا تتوقف الغارات من الجو
وايضا القصف ال مدفعي من مواقع مختلفه يتم
قصف مناطق ومنازل ومباني
سكنيه حيث يعني تظهر الصور بان عدد كبير
من المباني السكنيه تحديدا تلك المتاخمه
للحدود مع هذه المنطقه شرق قطاع غزه تم
تدميرها بالكامل هناك طيله الوقت ايضا
طيران حربي ومروحيات عسكريه من طراز
اباتشي تحلق في هذه المناطق وبين الحين
والاخر تقوم بقصف مواقع مختلفه سواء كان
في منطقه الشجاعيه حي الشجاعيه وفي منطقه
حي الزيتون وفي مناطق اخرى متفرقه ايضا
صباح هذا اليوم رصدنا قصف قصف مماثل في
المناطق الشماليه مع ال الحدود المتاخمه
للمناطق الشماليه في قطاع غزه في منطقه
بيت حنون وبيت لهيه رغم ان هذه المناطق
كانت بدايه التوغل البري الاسرائيلي ومن
اكثر المناطق ايضا التي تعرضت في بدايه
هذه الحرب للقصف الجوي الى ان تم تدمير
الجزء الاكبر تحديدا من بلده بيت حانون
لكن مع ذلك نرى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال
ينفذ ينفذ عمليات قصف متتاليه سواء كان من
قوات المدفعيه او من الجو وهذا اولا يدلل
على انه في بعض الاحيان ما زالت القوات
المتوغلة
داخل المناطق الشماليه تواجه مقاومين لكن
ايضا هناك من الواضح بان هناك تنفيذ للخطه
التي اعلن عنها اسرائيليا من قبل رئيس
الحكومه تحديدا بنيامين نتنياهو بانه يتم
مسح هذه المباني لاقامه او لانشاء منطقه
عازله في المستقبل بعد هذه الحرب ضمن ربما
الخلافات التي تصطدم معها يصد معها
نتنياهو تحديدا مع الاداره الامريكيه بشان
مستقبل غزه بعد انتهاء هذه الحرب